[Music]
in sex for rent news rent that's the
ideal situation how do you rent sex no
you pay for rent with your wee-wee
oh
sex for rent but you don't own it i
don't need to i just go
just three three pumps
we're done awesome
all right so this one's submitted by jay
from texas hey what's up hey jay
jay from texas
creepy landlords are offering desperate
women a place to stay
in exchange for sex this sounds fair to
me
here we go
it's just trading favors you know what
bart you're not alone it's like hey if
you mow my lawn i'll walk your dog
bam yeah tit for dick yeah there's a lot
of uh people responding to this story
saying the same thing it's like what
it's just a service
for something it's the barter system
they've been doing it for years oh since
colonial times but isn't it illegal
though someone made it illegal it used
to be legal if benjamin franklin did it
i don't know
i don't know i'm making [ __ ] up right
now i feel like sex for
a place to stay isn't prostitution i
think it has to be actual money money
yeah oh yeah because wait is escorts
getting like gifts is that count as
prostitution um i think escorting is
illegal because that's money but that's
a loophole if you were to have sex and
get a
handbag
you can't go to jail
i mean well
yeah whoever nobody can go to jail for
it oh interesting so anyways there's
these ads being posted around
and here's an example of one that's a
[ __ ] ad
no bills this is uh definitely not how
you get sex like type it bro
free bets it no bills fully furnished
ready to move in single lady only i'm a
single lettuce all i want in return is a
kiss and cuddle only
genuine jet text that's it that's not
even sex and your eyes are amazing he
has like 20 25 vision or some [ __ ] he's
just crazy good dude you see through
your
clothes how you got you pregnant
i got them done no it was sex
without a condom for a place to stay
i thought it was like for a little uh
sex sex action but she's like a little
kiss yeah shut the [ __ ] up it's never
just a little kiss on a cuddle it's cold
yeah it's called because um in this
article they're reporting that there's a
lot of craigslist ads claiming the same
thing like you know for the right lady
all i want is a little kiss and a cuddle
maybe once or twice a week but
that clearly means sex yeah i i get you
now this is where i will propose the
question now
uh
would you ladies i've always well i have
to there's no other women here besides
you guys exactly yeah so um i'm gonna
set the stipulations though it's not
gonna be once or twice a week it's once
a month
you just have to have sex with this guy
once a month and it's a fully furnished
place that you get to live in for as
long as you want but you only have to
have sex with him once
i'm too prideful dude pet house
situation high rise downtown what's my
situation what's the what does the place
look like and what does he look like
okay so he looks average as [ __ ]
okay like you wouldn't like when you
look by him you wouldn't think he's ugly
you wouldn't think he's attractive you
would just walk by him like that's a man
the place that uh he lives in is not a
too fancy place but it's a decent place
it's like a condo somewhere out in
alhambra or something but you broke but
you're broke as [ __ ]
uh you just have a regular job but you
came on some hard times because you got
sued and you
if not this place you'll be living in a
place sharing a room with like four
other people and
one bathroom i have a car own place you
have a car but your car that you have
right now only has a half a tank of gas
and that's all you can afford and three
wheels
and one spare and do i have isaac we'll
eliminate isaac out of this you didn't
you didn't have them
you take too long you're giving up
awesome
opportunities people are putting gold in
your face and you're just thinking about
it because i'm about to rent it to
somebody else
you better
hurry up and make your decision i'll
take it
bam suck in this dick i don't think so i
feel like i'd probably just figure out
other ways to make enough money to
survive that's the difference between a
guy and a girl huh yeah that's how we
have the vagina we're talking millions
and
here's the better picture how much is
rent here if you had to pay for it it
would be about 2 000 a month so it'd be
2 000 a month right if you were to work
somewhere else let's say you do and
you're making two thousand dollars a
month you would spend that on the rent
and then you'd be at zero
now you do a little hoo-ha action once a
month once a month you keep all two
thousand dollars
bam that's making four g's a month
pretty much
and that's how a pimp is made please no
i get pimped approach me with golden
opportunity and i will say yes it's so
interesting how that psyche works out
because i always wonder that because if
it was the guy where there was a lady
who put this ad out right and she just
looked average and she was like listen i
just need you to dick me down once a
month it's different because your dick
is going into something a dick isn't
going into you nah it's different
because society made y'all feel like
you're less than when you have some
random sex everybody likes sex i don't
feel less than sex in exchange for some
dope [ __ ] you would do it if there
wasn't the dumbass connotation they have
for women maybe for general women but
for me it's not i wouldn't feel
because whether it's going in or out is
not the issue like you wouldn't stick
your hand in alligator's mouth your body
part is your body part so that's not
even the argument the argument is guys
that would be willing to do it we would
do it to like
a lady we don't find attractive at all
for that prize or that that house that
place of sex because your guys sex is
different than a girl sex too but is it
[ __ ] anything yeah yeah there's no
emotion attached we're just more
financially intelligent
because look at look at look at just
having a gay couple right men gay men
they have way more sex than lesbian
couples it's just in your nature how do
we know that that's statistics look it
up oh like grinder and stuff they're
completely okay with hooking up and
they're completely open first and then
you talk about a relationship after all
the gay girls i know i always talk about
[ __ ] all the gay girls they're all
the gay girls i'm not saying that's the
majority but statistically speaking if
you're comparing two gay males to two
lesbians or two gay females you talked
about that on there was like statistics
proving yeah they have they have way
more sex but i still think it's for
those reasons because there is this
stigma about women and sex i agree i bet
in a super liberal ass place like san
francisco i bet the lesbians be [ __ ]
the same as regular dudes
i think he was talking about uh trading
sex for goods no but i'm saying the
stigma i'm talking about like these this
stigma applies to more and more
conservative places where people care
about oh that's not all lady acts or
whatever yeah but in a place that's very
liberal people don't give a [ __ ] about
what other people think i'm just gonna
do what i want like take vegas girls go
to vegas to [ __ ] random people all the
time
what are you talking about i'm agreeing
with them yeah i don't know i guess i
can only speak for myself then for me
it's more of like a pride thing like nah
[ __ ] you like yeah because i think maybe
it's because you feel well i feel or
it's rightfully so that i don't need you
to provide for me that's exactly what it
is so you'd rather be a homeless
prideful person i'll never be homeless
that's what she's saying like i don't
need your [ __ ] i'll never be homeless
two thousand minus two thousand zero
dollars i'll never be homeless she'll
never be homeless because she has that
option bro
[Laughter]
without that [ __ ] option i don't need
that [ __ ] option i'll never be
homeless but
with the story
as creepy as it sounds i don't think
it's that bad because it's not it's not
like a trick per se like yeah he's
talking in cold but you know what's
going on
and
it's if you want it
come do it it's not like yeah i'll let
you stay here rent free don't worry
about it then you move in it's like hey
but i was wondering if we could just
have sex with money you know what the
problem with that is though
is that what type of dude are you
[ __ ] that needs to put out an ad just
to get a little something it's even
that's the thing these sexiest dude
would do some [ __ ] like that because we
just like to [ __ ] that's so true it
could be ugly it could be a dude who's
hot and just a sex addict and wants to
have this little control type thing yeah
that's true that's the difference i
guess for guys prayer is fun no no
any guy baller poor handsome ugly
speaking from a female that gets hit on
right you guys can attest to this yeah
um the guys that will always approach
you i wasn't looking at you
the guys that will always approach you
and have more guts are usually the
[ __ ] busted ones shut you down go for
it celebrities
[Music]
girls can't be around celebrities if
they're not [ __ ] you want to come
through you gotta [ __ ] i'm speaking on
an advocate but that's but that that's
what this is you want to live here have
sex with me that's that's a different
level though but no but these are rich
successful guys who don't need to do
[ __ ] like that like you don't have to
force women to have sex with you if they
want to be around but they do it no i
think that's a that's a whole different
situation though it's a different
situation it's the same mentality is
what i'm saying i don't know it's just
saying look
if you want this i want that i think
it's you're dangling the carrot yeah the
girl for sex in many different ways
sometimes it's a house sometimes it's
for fame sometimes for whatever but it's
the same
i think the difference between the
celebrity situation is the fact that um
there isn't anything like a real come up
from it it's like an emotional thing you
know i mean like i [ __ ] a celebrity
you know what i mean so the trade-off is
a little bit different and it kind of
like adheres to her argument because
it's talking about sexuality being an
emotional thing that's aside from just
trading your body for something else
it's more like they get something very
valuable out of it it has nothing to do
with a monetary come up yeah no for the
girl it's different i'm just saying that
both spectrums of god
think the same yeah yeah for sure
i'll give you something for what i want
for sure but i think we were
specifically talking about this
situation where you're saying that you
might get a good looking dude you might
get an ugly dude and i'm thinking when
it's like this i highly doubt that it's
going to be
it's going to be cool handwriting looks
just like chris brown
i guarantee you a celebrity with a girl
on hard times well if you need a place
to stay i got an extra room yeah that's
different
that approach is already less [ __ ]
desperate and creepy and freaking of fat
and stinky like that one no it's the
exact same amount of creepiness i got i
got a place for you to stay just have
sex with me like that's creepy this one
is less creepy to me because it's it's
not direct it's not hey you it's if
there are any women out there who are
down for this let me know
that's that passive [ __ ] so he's out in
the club still trying to get [ __ ]
meanwhile let me have a second avenue of
[ __ ]
oh no i think that's way more creepy
because sometimes you are [ __ ] what
is this fly fishing and you leave the
three fishing poles that's like the
direct one is is not as creepy because
you know what you're getting into so on
the spot you can already be like oh no
i'm good i don't know they're both
pretty [ __ ] creepy
it was uh
printed with a photo of this man and a
picture of the place
less creepy i still think it's creepy
but then i feel like all right well my
imagination is i can put that to rest
because now i know exactly what maybe
how i'm trying to think of too
especially from a woman's perspective is
like um i don't think let's say i'm a
woman right
i'm not looking at this i'm like okay i
feel like at that point because you're
giving me this for this now this is your
property i think for a moral issue for
me if i was a woman that's where i would
have an issue with this like oh it
doesn't feel like a trade-off it feels
more like i you owe me now and you get
to use me at your will call for once a
month yeah i guess that would be kind of
like the mental issue i'm saying if i'm
a girl i'm like okay what's up what's up
i'm like okay i don't like that because
now i'm just your little pocket [ __ ]
but then at the same time you still get
a place to live
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode if you haven't already make sure
to hit that subscribe button because we
upload videos every single day for you
guys now to watch more videos check them
out up here
[Music]
bye